bienvenidos vamos a resolver el problema
número 96 nos piden que resolvamos esto
un medio más se abren corchetes dos
tercios por tres octavos todo esto
dividido entre cuatro y todo esto se le
restan nueve dieciseisavos hoy ya
sabemos cuál es el orden en el que
debemos resolver las operaciones así que
de entrada veo que este tres se va con
este tres y nos queda esta parte como
dos octavos entonces esto es un medio
más
esta parte de aquí
nos quedó como dos octavos que lo
podemos reducir como un cuarto un cuarto
en 34 y esto menos nueve dieciseisavos
916 aus esto de aquí un cuarto entre un
cuarto es lo mismo que tener un cuarto
por un cuarto acuérdense que esto que
está dividiendo puede pasar
multiplicando con su recíproco
un cuarto por un cuarto 4x4 es 16 esto
es igual a un dieciseisavo
entonces todo esto de acá me dio esto y
eso me dio esto ahora agregó los demás
elementos aquí tengo un medio
esto - 9 dieciseisavos y ya que tengo
todo como dieciseisavos
bueno excepto esta parte pues vamos a
dejarla en términos de 16avos
dieciseisavos porque 8 x 26 16
más un dieciseisavo
- nueve dieciseisavos 8 19 - 9 es igual
a cero
y todo esto pues bueno fue para tener un
0 que es nuestra opción
muy bien siguiente problema número 97 el
agua consiste en oxígeno e hidrógeno y
la proporción aproximada de la masa del
hidrógeno con respecto a la del oxígeno
es de 2 a 16 aproximadamente cuántos
gramos de oxígeno hay en 144 gramos de
agua bueno nos están dando como dato que
la proporción del hidrógeno con respecto
al oxígeno
es igual a 216
y también nos están diciendo que la suma
de oxígeno e hidrógeno nos va a dar 144
hidrógeno más oxígeno igual a 144 gramos
144 aunque vamos a dejar esta proporción
como una razón tenemos que el hidrógeno
con respecto al oxígeno es igual a 2
entre 16 o si lo simplificamos va a ser
igual a 1 entre 8
y nos preguntan los gramos de oxígeno
así que vamos a sustituir el oxígeno
bueno de hecho aquí vamos a despejar el
hidrógeno porque quiero dejarlo todo en
términos de oxígeno aquí es el hidrógeno
va a ser igual a un octavo
de oxígeno y esto lo voy a sustituir acá
está h esta h la voy a sustituir aquí
entonces me va a quedar un octavo de
oxígeno más este oxígeno va a ser igual
a 144 ok un octavo más un entero pues
que puedo también lo podemos expresar
como ocho octavos una octava más ocho
octavos va a ser igual a nueve octavos
de oxígeno igual a 144 nos interesa
saber el oxígeno así que vamos a poner
el oxígeno es igual a 144 por
creo que podemos hacer algunos términos
vamos a dividir 144 entre 9 144 entre 9
que me parece que es una dicción exacta
va a ser 9 x 19 menos 14 va a ser 5 se
baja el 46 por 9 54 y aquí restamos está
54 nos queda 0 en efecto una edición
exacta así que esto estos 2 los puedo
sustituir por 16
esto me queda igual a 16 por 8 y esto es
igual a 128
entonces voy a tener 128 gramos de
oxígeno en 144 gramos de agua y esta es
mi opción de
siguiente pregunta nos dan esto x por 2
x 1 igual a 0 y también nos dan esta
ecuación x más un medio por 2 x menos 3
todo esto es igual a 0 y nos piden
encontrar el valor de x esto es
interesante ya que de esta primera
ecuación nos dicen que para que esto sea
0 esta x podría ser igual a 0 o este
término de acá podría ser también 0 y de
esta otra ecuación nos dicen que podemos
tener este término como 0 o este otro
término también que valga 0 es la única
forma que tenemos para que el resultado
sea hacer si multiplico esta primera
ecuación si la desarrollo me va a quedar
x x 2x va a ser 2 x al cuadrado x x 1 es
igual a equis y sabemos que esto va a
ser igual a 0 y ahora vamos
en esta segunda ecuación x x 2x va a ser
2 x al cuadrado x x menos 3 va a ser
igual a menos 3 x 1 medio x 2 x va a ser
igual a x porque un medio por 2 se
vuelve a una unidad x
un medio por menos 3 va a ser igual a
menos 3 medios
vamos a simplificar un poco más esto
bueno todos nos ponemos que esto es
igual a cero es 2 x al cuadrado menos 3
x mas x nos queda menos 2 x menos 2 x
menos tres medios
esto es igual a cero y esto también es
igual a cero por lo tanto estas dos van
a ser iguales
estas dos x al cuadrado más x mas x va a
ser igual a esto bueno vamos a
simplificarlo el chiste es dejar a la
equis solita este 2x cuadrada se va con
esta dos x cuadrada aquí este menos 2 x
lo voy a pasar aquí sumando o voy a
sumar 2 x en ambos lados de la ecuación
2 x + x me va a quedar 3 x
al menos 2 x + 2 x se va a eliminar y me
va a quedar solamente el menos 3 medios
x si yo divido todo entre 3 va a ser
igual a menos tres medios por un tercio
estos elementos se van y me queda que
eso es igual a menos un medio muy bien
esta es la opción b vamos bastante bien
ok el último problema del vídeo el
problema número 99 en una escala que
mide la intensidad de cierto fenómeno la
lectura de edemas uno corresponde a una
intensidad que es diez veces mayor que
la lectura de n en dicha escala la
lectura correspondiente a una intensidad
de 8 cuantas veces es mayor que la
intensidad de una lectura de 3 bueno lo
que nos están diciendo aquí es que si
tenemos la lectura de n
1 este va a ser igual a 10 veces la
lectura de n
si tenemos la lectura de 3
de 3 a este vamos a llamarle 1
entonces la lectura de cuatro va a ser
igual a 1 por 10 que es el anterior será
10 para la lectura de 5 tendremos esto
por 10 será 100 para la lectura de 6
tendremos esto por 10 que será 1000
estamos agregando un cero en cada
incremento de la escala 7
tendremos 1000 por 10 10.000
y finalmente 8 que es el que nos
interesa será 10.000 por 10 100 mil
así que este 8 en esta escala va a ser
100.000 veces mayor que 3 esto lo
podemos expresar también para no poner
tanto cero como un 10 elevado a las 5 11
seguido de cinco ceros esto también lo
podemos expresar como un 10 a la 4
etcétera etcétera lo podemos hacer con
todos estos pero pues bueno es lo que me
piden y esto corresponde a la opción c
y con eso terminamos los problemas de
este vídeo